we're you know going into the magical
side of the Marvel Universe and also
exploring a new dimension so it's very
exciting in that sense you wonder what I
see in your future
possibility
when I started on the film in September
2014 scott derrickson the director had
already started to gather a lot of
images and references from comics and
from you know films and photographs and
paintings charlie wood which the
production designer came to LA as well
and we did a lot of brainstorming
together with Scott and people at Marvel
to try and establish and define what
what the world of dr. strange would be
so it was a kind of an interpretation of
what was on the page a long time ago and
trying to make it fresh and new for
today the Marvel films are produced
initially as a 2d film and then what we
do is convert them in post-production
into a 3d presentation it's sort of
turning the entire movie into a visual
effect even movie even shots that
wouldn't have visual effects otherwise
become a visual effect when you convert
them into 3d
3d is it's a whole sort of additional
set of tools for storytelling really you
know it's like taking a movie that's
black and white turning you in the color
how are you getting the chances of
viewer to see the movie the way the way
that you would have experienced it in
real life it's free it can be very
immersive one of the things we try to do
with 3d is not just keep it deep all the
time just you sort of audience fatigues
after a while compare it to like a
musical score but if you just played it
loud constantly it just becomes all the
same whereas if you modulate then people
really feel those big moments and they
and then you give people a rest and then
you really feel another big moment 3d is
not a new art form I mean some of the
earliest cinema was using was
experimenting the 3d and certainly in
the 50s have had a big resurgence so
with this sort of gimmicky black and
white 3d that was happening at the time
people kind of refer to that is 3d and
then in the 80s there was another sort
of period of 3d where people were
suddenly leveraging color and polarisers
to be able to separates even if the red
and blue glasses anymore and all that so
every time there's this sort of
technological advance when we go back to
3d and this time around the big change
was really that we could leverage all
the modern computing tools that we have
available in making films to really make
an digital projection and everything
else to make it really clean and a much
more pleasant viewing experience for the
audience it was a chance to sort of like
venture into places that we had never
been and that's what the multiverse
gives us right whether is in the magic
mystery tour on in the Dark Dimension
with Dormammu or when we go into the
mirror dimension or the astral plane any
of those different places it was a
chance to do something completely
different than we had seen before and
yet believe that this was a journey of a
superhero you know we do a lot of things
that are incredibly for real
and then we had to create them first and
then completely tear them apart that was
a fun part to tear something apart in a
way that you can still tell your story
that is visually stunning that is a
little bit dizzying if you would and yet
people could follow the story in a
whichever dimension you're in and it
gives you a ride if you go out to any
theater you're gonna see conceivably a
very nice presentation in a very nice
theater with leather seats and all that
stuff and that's great but what they've
done in imax is they take in our movie
and actually reprocessed it to actually
reduce the noise increase the sharpness
actually enhance the presentation on a
shot by shot artist-driven process so we
monitor that process and we work with
them on it so it's not something that's
done in a vacuum we're a part of it and
it's actually an extension of our
process we also do additional color
grading here so it's like taking the
movie and just turning it up to 11 as we
were doing especially in a film like
looks too strange where we're you know
we're exploring new dimensions and we're
really going big on like New York and
Hong Kong where you know it's like big
scale sequences I think having the extra
size of the screen and the resolution
and all the sound coming with it I think
it's way more immersive for the for the
audience I like the idea of being it's
it's almost like you're enveloped by the
image it's it allows you to sort of like
it's like the walls disappear
and I'm in it it doesn't get any bigger
than that IMAX is delivering the biggest
canvas that there is out there so it's
an opportunity for us to to tell this
big epic story with magic and crazy
stuff going on and do it in a way that
really does adjust this this the way we
intended to see man I always tell people
to see it this way sand we have about 60
minutes or more of the film that is in
IMAX and for these 60 minutes were going
into a bigger format as well you know
the film is formatted for two for oh but
for these special sequences were going
to the full IMAX format which is one
point
nine and we've you know put extra care
into adding some extra things top and
bottom of the frame and making sure that
there is more to the experience when you
go to IMAX the idea was what can we do
for the story that will work for IMAX
because we want to tell that story in
mercifully but we also didn't want to
have this cryptic in and out in and out
in and out of the different ratios so we
decided that the person that dr. strange
was up to when he gets to Kathmandu in
Nepal is one person and the person that
he becomes once he's there is a
different person
different times of his journey so what
we decided to do is was up to the
arrival to Kathmandu is a twofer oh and
once we get to Kathmandu we opened it up
as if you could see that he was growing
and he was learning to be the best of
who he could be when I was sitting for
the first time in the IMAX theatre even
for me it was like oh wow it was like a
to rediscovery of the film which blew me
away really did and I was very you know
moved by it
be careful which paths you travel down
strange stronger men than you have
passed away I've seen the movie a few
times and traditional theaters versus
the IMAX theatre and it's more immersive
it's more impactful and you really feel
like you're in the movie so it's it's
obviously the screen is very large and
the presentation is excellent
those are important things and great
we're not doing it just because we can
do it we're just doing it because it
brings something special to the film
it's a big example of that is there's a
scene at the beginning of the film which
is called we call the magic mystery tour
where a dr. strange is pushed into all
these dimensions by the the ancient one
and that's the you know one of the first
time in the film where we actually go to
1.9 and the experience is very different
because you are travelling through all
these space and all these the
and it's it's it just you know it makes
it bigger and more immersive it really
feels like when it's like the shackles
are released in a way and you suddenly
are just looking out into this because
of the scale of the film and the scale
of the magic in the film I feel like I'm
accident definitely the right format for
it because it gives us the extra space
and the extra immersion for the audience
to go into the film and really be taken
by it everything that is available to us
we use it everything that is perhaps
available we'll try it and everything
that is not available we'll ask about it
where were those kind of people I've
spent so many years peering through time
looking for you
you